qu'est ce que tu fais là je me suis fait
la place enfin ses choix la révolution
de 68 se fait aussi au cinéma les films
valérie avec danielle ouimet je suis
bien comme ça tu ne te couches pas et le
viol d'une jeune fille douce de gilles
carle met en scène une sexualité
débridée du jamais vu dans un québec
encore plus vite un chef de bande job ce
afin d'éviter toute erreur sur la
personne
je vérifier moi même soigneusement
chaque information obtenue est longtemps
que vous êtes marié bientôt trois mois
et demi je te juge se voit pas pour la
première fois des artistes québécois
osent écrire jouer et chanter dans leur
langue
nous ça allait plus loin que la kz1 ça
allait dans la grammaire fauqué qu'on a
employé les anglicismes pas en veux tu
en voilà ce qu'on appelait le joual à
l'époque le fameux joie
[Musique]
du coup j'ai choisi le joual parce que
c'est la ram dans laquelle je parlais
dans que je pensais alors que j'aurai
avec en hamac chose
que reste-t-il de cette année charnière
où les canadiens français sont devenus
des québécois jetant dessus ton refus on
nous en parler sur scène comme il le
faisait dans la rue fait les braques dit
ne pas s'inspirer des artistes de
l'époque même si chante parfois leur
zone
[Musique]
je suis jeune héritier sans savoir mais
c'est peut-être aussi la notion de
liberté dans la création si peut-être
qu'ils reviennent
il n'imaginait un imaginaire
complètement débridée c'est un équilibre
et qui après et en sang selon elle
semble beaucoup à cette époque des
chanteurs la française basse est correct
je dire si c'est ça qu'on veut faire
mais je comprends que à l'époque ça
relevait peut-être d'un espèce de
comportement de coloniser à quelque part
je pense est une prise de possession de
de son identité traité comme un
révélateur d'une appropriation culturel
franchement quitter
[Applaudissements]
la fin du monde c'est la seule chanson
de l'osstidcho que louise forestier
souhaiterait que les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui
écoute ça décrypte la dérive
climatologique de la planète exactement
pourquoi vous voulez que les jeunes
écoutent ça mais parce que la minurso
vimont au bout de jardin que ma langue
êtes vous d'accord exemple pour tous je
suis content que luis veille un beau
potager
mais même si un combat c'est même pas
c'est même pas la planisphère moyer trop
trop mais c'est la jeunesse c'est tout
ce qui commence et des enfants qui est
qui qui m'importe chanter et jouer en
québécois est devenu banal normal
tellement que les jeunes artistes ont du
mal à croire que cette langue qu'ils
parlent sans gel ou ne l'entendaient
même pas sur no sign é li a à peine 50
ans
[Musique]